es ist montag die motivation ist
hoffentlich hoch wir sind da wir machen
ein bauch special training heute mit
euch das heißt fokus wird definitiv auf
der bauchmuskulatur gerade und seitlich
liegen mit der alternativ übungen dass
man keine überlastungen bringen
wir trainieren mit euch jetzt die dritte
woche im lock down und wir hoffen wir es
jetzt immer noch dabei und mit
trainingseifer so wie wir am arbeiten
wir das ist der herbert bis bin ich der
beta und heute da manuel mit dabei aber
man darf die bieten stell dir einfach
ganz gut selbst vor man sportlich
schwergewicht liegt auf spielkarten und
ausdauer super danke meinen was machst
du in deiner freizeit sport mäßig also
allein spielt jetzt halt schlecht
fußball was man als alternative zum
lockern
ich bin ein spieler und darf dank des
spitzensport konzepts momentan auch
wieder trainieren sehr gut
das ist auch wieder unser schlagwort
unser stichwort spitzensportler dürfen
trainieren die werden regelmäßig
getestet wir haben zwar keine
spitzensportler mehr
aber wir werden auch täglich getestet
und dürfen der senator auf engen raum
zusammen arbeiten zusammen trainieren
und mit euch ein tolles programm machen
okay dann würde vorschlagen fangen wir
an mit aufwärmen never change a winning
system wir beginnen mit stand lauf was
erwartet euch heute bauchmuskeltraining
das heißt bauchmuskulatur das richtig
brennen das richtig belastet sein mit
wie gesagt ein paar alternativen übungen
im rücken in den beinen
ja wohl aber die masse wird der brauch
belastet wenn man gleich angreifen dazu
vorwärts
am kreisel rückwärts und gleich gegen
gleich bitte mit dazu probier zumal die
hüfte stabil körper unter spannung
richtung wechseln und kurz stehenbleiben
auslauf dann machen wir eine entspannte
variante für die nackenmuskulatur dazu
das heißt blick wendung linke seite
rechte seite und kopf neigen nach oben
nach unten und den kopf linke seite
kippen rechte seite kippen wenn es
kracht in der halswirbelsäule dann so
das ok sein solange schmerzfrei passiert
das ganz okay weil man noch den kopf von
der linken seite über die brust auf die
rechte seite und wieder zurück
ordentlich gesagt fahren wir wieder mit
bewegen an lockeres hampelmann springen
zur erinnerung wer die beweglichkeit
oder schmerzen in der schulter hat kann
die hände einfach herunter hängen lassen
oder nur bis zur halben höhe hochheben
verschiedene varianten möglich
auch die ausfallschritte mit den händen
nach vorn und zur seite im wechsel macht
hat gewisse kreative aufgabe dazu wie
gesagt wie wichtig dieser dynamik dabei
zu haben
in bewegung zu kommen den kreislauf zu
aktivieren die muskulatur vorzubereiten
und entsprechend die gelenke auf die
nachfolgende belastung vorzubereiten
okay aus lockern stehen bleiben wir
gehen gleich weiter falten die hände
sozusagen und kreisen die handgelenke
und wir wechseln die richtung war kann
ruhiger schöne dynamik drin sein
und noch eine richtung wechseln und
einmal noch richtung wechseln gehen wir
die hände gleichzeitig hoch kreisen im
unterarm shooter bleibt einigermaßen
stabil und der übung
bewegt sich richtung wechseln
johannes kurz konzentrieren
jetzt bewegen sich beide hände in eine
richtung richtungswechsel andere
richtung gerner kurz wieder ausloggen
die arme
gehen wir mal eine etwas breitere stand
position gehen wir den oberkörper nach
vor und rotieren den oberkörper in der
vorhalte general
da fahren wir mal langsam an
schauen wir mal dass man die bewegung
hinein kommen der wirbelsäule gehen wir
die möglichkeit dem drama bisschen
schwung zu holen entsprechend sich
vorzubereiten und langsam steigern man
dann das tempo
das heißt immer ab ist die flotte werden
dass man mal eine ansprechende stampa
haben gerne atmen nicht vergessen
ja gut und da mehr ausrichten ausloggen
körper durch schütteln und wieder
bislang stand laufen gleich die hände
dazu nehmen
boxen auf
wollen wir noch drei sekunden
ok
immer wieder stehen gehen wir die hände
in die hüfte kreisen einmal nur das
becken dass der oberkörper bleibt einmal
so ruhig wie möglich
und dann wäre man langsam größer mit den
kreisen
bis man irgendwann einmal den ganzen
körper drehen dann wechseln die richtung
bleiben im großen kreis
und wer mal langsam wieder kleiner mit
den kreis und bis wir wieder nur das
becken kreisen
genau dann machen wir zwischendrin eine
übung im sitzen das heißt einmal in den
gerät stets bitte hinten kein zeuge
abstützen kein problem und gibt zur
medizin nach innen und nach außen haben
wir schon kopfhälfte mobilisieren
hüftgelenk dann nehmen wir dann auch den
unteren rücken kehren mit dazu dass die
beine anwinkeln leicht geöffnete
position knie zum boden bewegen links
und rechts im wechsel
genau und stehen wir wieder auf bewegen
wir uns wieder bisserl stand lauf und
die herz familie wieder ein staat und
den stopp auf der startseite flotte auf
der stopp normal weiterlaufen stadt
rostock und statt
rostock einmal das ganze noch statt
er starb kurz aus locker mal
durchschnaufen durchatmen
wie gesagt wie wiederholen wir dann auch
mal wir haben das schon erklärt wir
trainieren mit und wie einsatzsoldaten
und wir versuchen das training für euch
so herunterzubrechen dass jahr
entsprechend was mitnehmen können dabei
das heißt wenn ihr heute euch bisschen
mehr belasten wollen können sie immer
wieder ein zusatzgewicht verwenden
daher wird hat sich die kapelle schon
hergerichtet und wenn ihr mehr belastung
wird können sie auch nach den 30
sekunden thema generell arbeitszeit
haben und dann 30 sekunden pause dann
arbeit jetzt einfach wieder durch ja
beide varianten habt ihr da als
möglichkeit ok mobilisieren was stört
uns noch mal zusammen schon relativ weit
unten knie und sprunggelenk bitte
genauer handy aufs knie und bewegen nach
links kreisen nach rechtskreisen porträt
jungen unter sprunggelenk für it
unternehmer gleich wieder bislang
gleichgewichts komponente mit das heißt
das linke bein hochheben und im
sprunggelenk kreisen und die richtung
wechseln und die seite wechseln wieder
kreisen
und die richtung wechseln
kerner und ausloggen und ich glaube sein
für unser bauchtraining jetzt ganz gut
vorbereitet wir machen zehn übungen wie
gesagt 30 sekunden belasten 30 sekunden
pause die die richtig gas geben wollen
machen eine minute durchgehende
belastung und wechseln dann nur quasi
auf die nächste übung wir starten mit
der ersten übung die kammer bereits der
klassische sieht ab das heißt einmal
zweimal bitte position
ich wiederhole noch mal ganz kurz war
auf worauf kommt es an
in der bewegung selbst bleiben die beine
auf der matte der oberkörper ist
losgelöst vom boden und bewegt sich nach
oben
die hände kann ich in vorhalte haben
dass das ganze ein bisschen einfacher
ich kann sie verschränken vor der brust
wird das ganze schwieriger oder ich kann
sie auch die schläfe geben dann wird das
ganze noch ein bisschen schwieriger
wichtig ist die fersen bleiben am boden
wenn die fersen abheben weil wir jetzt
mit der hand macht solch ein bisschen
leichter in drei sekunden legen wir los
30 sekunden arbeitszeit und los geht's
auch da wenn sich erinnert haben wir
bereits besprochen wenn der bauchmuskeln
permanent unter spannung ist dann ist es
super für unsere muskulatur
das heißt nicht zwischendrin den
oberkörper ganz ablegen und nicht ganz
ganz hoch gehen so dass die
bauchmuskulatur anspannung verliert
sondern immer unter zug bleiben da
braucht man immer unter spannung fünf
sekunden hat es noch die 30 sekunden
sind vorbei 30 sekunden pause mangel
macht weiter der gesagt er trainiert
durch habe durch die pause du kannst
kurz durchschnaufen aus lockern wir
machen inzwischen ausfallschritte als
vorbereitung einmal aufstehen
du kannst dein zusatzgewicht teilnehmern
zum vorzeigen nehmen eine wasserflasche
als zusatzgewicht als kette bell war es
auch immer in die ausfallschritt
position gehen
ihr bleibt dann vorne und bewegt sich
nur auf und ab in fünf sekunden geht es
mit der zweiten übung los also mangel
bereitmachen position wechseln
ausbauschritt linke seite vorne und geht
los achtet darauf dass das knie die knie
spitze nicht so weit vorne ist es ja ein
bisschen länger den ausfallschritt bitte
ja super und hinten runter gehen dass
das knie nicht
nach vorschiebt oberkörper bleibt
aufrecht bleibt stabil grundspannung in
der rumpfmuskulatur ist immer da fünf
sekunden oder an die ersten 30 sekunden
wieder vorbei
21 und ausnahme macht weiter die übung
und herbert wir gehen in dieser variante
seitlich das bitte einmal auf die matte
jetzt wichtig legt eure knie auf die
linke seite hinüber genau und zieht mit
den händen auf die rechte seite im
vorhalte vor der brust oder bei den
schläfen möglich das heißt er kommt
wirklich sauber in die seitlichen
bauchmuskulatur jetzt beim training
immerhin in fünf sekunden geht es mit
der übung asche los 21 und arbeiten nach
den 30 sekunden wenn zehn übungen machen
wir ganz kurze pause und dann macht man
einen zweiten durchgang das ist richtig
auszeit verbraucht dass man was er ist
doch und der spürbar nicht ganz ablegen
man nicht ganz runter gehen noch sieben
sekunden dann sollen die ersten 30
vorbei wenn man die minute durch
arbeitet und im zuge der minute geht
irgendwann wie man so schön sagt zeit
aus das gas aus ja dann kann man
natürlich sie zwischendrin mal kurze
pause auch können
du warst weiteren gesagt die minute wird
durchgearbeitet
denn die pause jetzt mal unten und arme
oben die muskulatur die spannung raus
nehmen außer schritte auf der anderen
seite rechtes bein nach vor vorbereiten
zehn sekunden drei haus das geschäft
manuell gerade position oberkörper
aufrecht in drei sekunden gehts los
21 und zeit läuft auch da natürlich wenn
ihr fragen habt stellt das posters
kommentiert das ganze dann findet sich
eine antwort wir haben
sportwissenschaftler im hintergrund der
ich gerne alle fragen dazu beantworten
ihr habt es noch zehn sekunden
noch fünf vier drei zwei eins und die
ersten 30 sekunden sind wieder vorbei
und ja der jetzt der aufmerksam mit
dabei was kann noch kommen wenn man
zuerst sieht es recht gehabt haben
machen jetzt zweite seite sieht
allerdings das heißt die knie auf die
rechte seite fallen lassen
handy wieder in diese position die von
der belastung her für euch passt in
vorhalte vor der brust oder bei den
schläfen und in 10 sekunden geht es mit
der zweiten seite sieht ob es also los
noch 321 und zeit läuft auch wieder
versuchen nicht mit schwung hoch zu
reißen sondern mit der muskelkraft zu
arbeiten der kopf auch hier bleibt in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule und jetzt
sieht es mit der kraft der seitlichen
bauchmuskulatur ihren oberkörper nach
oben und daher gut meine ganz hoch genau
wie kurze entspannungsphase in der
muskulatur und war nicht die spannung
aufrecht halte dann glaubst du die
letzten 5 6 cm der bewegung weg um 21 30
sekunden sind durch nachdem sie tipps
auf der linken seite machen jetzt einmal
alternativ eine übung für den rücken
wir haben zwar gesagt wir machen ein
bock special ja aber das braucht immer
zwischen trainer bislang die muskulatur
und damit es nicht zu anstrengend wird
haben ähnlich sagt einmal die beine mit
dabei und jetzt einmal den rücken mit
dabei erst die rücken übung ist einfach
das aufrichten des oberkörpers dass die
beine die zehen sind am boden da hinten
ist unter voller spannung und ich habe
meinen oberkörper los vom boden auf und
runter geht's los 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit jetzt da könnte ich
natürlich schwer machen indem wir die
hände nach vorstreckt und ein bisschen
einfacher machen meine die ellenbogen
nach hinten zieht ja sehr wichtig kopf
bleibt in verlängerung der wirbelsäule
der hintern ist gespannt und ich reiße
die bewegung nicht sondern ich ziehe
muskulär mit der kraft meiner
rückenstrecke noch drei sekunden und
zeit aus 30 sekunden sind durch mangel
du hast nur 30 sekunden belastung passt
ist in ordnung herzliche anstrengung
heraus ja aber wie er sagt ist in
ordnung dass sie dadurch nächste übung
die man mitnehmen ist wieder eine für
den bauch das heißt in der rückenlage
die einfachere variante
ihr lasst sie fersen am boden richtet in
den oberkörper hoch und dreht album
rechts zum linken knie und umgekehrt und
die etwas komplexere variante zeigt dass
der mangel vor wechsel
los geht's ist der radfahrer mit
zusätzlichen bein strecken genau das
heißt album zum knie und immer wieder
zwischen drinnen die beine strecken wenn
das 30 sekunden macht glaubt die
bauchmuskulatur ist gut spürbar
und wenn die 30 sekunden noch verlängern
will scans erklären auf die übungs
variante von herbert ausweichen dass er
die beine am boden last und nur den
oberkörper hin und her rotiert genau 30
sekunden habt okay die zweiten 30
sekunden nutzen wir jetzt die nächste
übung vorzuzeigen das heißt graue beine
das ist wieder zum auslaufen der
bauchmuskulatur in 15 sekunden geht es
dann gleich wieder los jetzt haben wir
vor und was geht es wichtig ist knie
sind gestreckt ja hintern ist
automatischen der opposition angespannt
und der rückenstrecke arbeitet 30
sekunden volle belastung mal zwei
sekunden anne und los rückenstrecke
arbeit geht schon los
ihr kennt die hände noch vor strecken so
wie es da der fall ist erkennt dass er
war verschränken und den kopf ablegen
das ist nicht so tragisch was da herum
passiert arbeiten dort gestern die
lenden muskulatur das heißt der
rückenstrecke auf höhe der
lendenwirbelsäule und zehn sekunden hat
es noch
noch 321 ersten 30 sekunden durch
wir wechseln wieder in die rückenlage
und machen die nächsten übung führen
bauch wir zeigen euch wieder vor die
klassischen crunches das heißt jetzt für
den bereich der oberen bauchmuskulatur
können die füße anwinkeln hände streckt
nach oben und erzählt es die schultern
weg vom boden und zieht es nur 3 bis 5
cm hoch und wieder runter und hoch und
wieder runter etwas leichter füße am
boden und noch etwas leichter händler in
vorhalte aber diesmal nur die kurze
bewegung hochziehen fertig nicht ganz
hoch 30 sekunden arbeitszeit jetzt und
das spürt ganz deutlich den unterschied
zuerst war man großflächig auf der
bauchmuskulatur oder auf der linken oder
auf der rechten seite jetzt einmal ganz
genau im bereich der oberen
bauchmuskulatur und die fängt richtig zu
brennen an
und das ist gut so die gehört belastet
damit sie daraus entwickelt 30 sekunden
sind vorbei das heißt die erste die
erste halbzeit so quasi ist erledigt
manuel macht nur weiter auf die zweite
minute und die letzte übung die zehnte
übung noch mal zweite gleiche und auch
hintereinander den sogenannten der
sogenannte fersen berühren das heißt er
hebt die schultern weg vom boden und
jetzt klopft sie mit ihren fingerspitzen
rechte ferse linke ferse
das heißt jetzt hat seinen wechsel
trainern wieder in der seitlichen
bauchmuskulatur und in 30 kunden geht es
also los
21 und gas geben letzte übung erster
durchgang der nach kopps kurzzeit die
bauchmuskulatur etwas zu regenerieren
schultern sind weg vom boden genau und
die fingerspitzen berühren die verse
sehen sie konnten ja atmen nicht
vergessen weiterschlafen 21 30 sekunden
durch
ich habe da mal kurze pause schlug
trinken mal macht seine minute noch
fertig ihr die richtig gas geben zu
hause macht saadi minute fertig in 20
sekunden hauptgeschäft und dann machen
wir alle gemeinsam eine kurze pause 15
sekunden bauchmuskulatur ist ein freier
ja fast kopf bitte gerade in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule genau hat
es immer wieder denken 321 anpassbar
muskulatur aus lockern ausklopfen
ausschüttung alles gut erste hälfte
erster durchgang hat erledigt hat es
geschafft wir machen jetzt da einen
zweiten durchgang wieder mit 30 30 wir
wechseln die belastung das heißt jetzt
macht der herbert die volle minute durch
und da mal die 30 sekunden variante
damit man beide varianten da ganz gut
abgedeckt haben heute das thema wie
gesagt bauchmuskulatur im fokus nächste
einheit wenn man dann machen die
rückenmuskulatur im fokus das heißt
gerade für eine aufrechte körperhaltung
aufrechte position schmerzfreien alltag
zu erleben ist der rücken ganz ganz
wichtig und allem auch deswegen werden
wir das jetzt da haben wir jetzt
gewichtet heute bauch und das nächste
mal dann das thema rückenmuskulatur ok
habe etwas von dir ein zum thema
bauchmuskulatur was ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass man es oft und viel
trainiert der harz mit zwei worten
perfekt beschrieben den bauch karma
permanent fordernden kann man permanent
belasten der regeneriert relativ rasch
und der hort ganz wichtige aufgabe in
unserem muskelkraft nämlich die
stabilisierung des oberkörpers genau wie
oft trainierst du dein bauch in der
woche
sollte er öfters perfekte erkenntnis
selbsterkenntnis 1 und als wären wir
dann schauen wir sind der praxis in der
durchführung im zweiten durchgang aus
schaut in 30 sekunden fertig sagt start
mal wieder los oder aber nicht sorgen
ok erste übung sieht es gerade versucht
es wieder an die wichtigen bewegungs
knotenpunkte zu denken das heißt heiß
ist in verlängerung also der kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule der relativ
gerade spannung aufbauen mit händen an
der schläfe vor der brust in vorhalte
fersen sind am boden und die bewegung
nicht ins maximum nach oben und nicht
ablegen dass der bauch unter strom steht
und los geht's und an wichtigen punkte
vergessen atmen wenn nur wenn die
muskulatur sauerstoff kriegt dann kann
sie entsprechend leistungsfähig sein und
funktionieren
sehen sie konnten dann ist der erste die
erste übung bereits wieder abgeschlossen
noch 5 4 3 2 1 und 30 sekunden durch
ich sehe etwas erleichterung dass jetzt
die 30 sekunden belastung da ist
anstrengend die ersten minuten
ja also hochachtung für euch zu hause
den minute durch trainieren und großer
respekt auch denen die dabei sind und
auch 30 sekunden wirklich intensiv an
ihrer fitness arbeiten
die zweite übung waren ausfallschritte
rechte seite nach vor moralische
bewegungs punkte game material position
wechseln herbert 30 sekunden sind vorbei
ist es einen möglichst großen
ausfallschritt habe es dass die das
vordere knie nicht über die zehenspitzen
hinausschiebt dass wir hinten runter
gehen können der oberkörper bleibt
aufrecht die brüste stolz
genau so gefällt mir das und die
beinachse sollte stabil sein das heißt
sprunggelenk kniegelenk hüfte bleibt in
einer ebene des knie zog mit links raus
des zucht nicht rechts raus sondern es
geht wie auf schienen auf und ab
und die ersten 30 sekunden haben wir
erledigt erarbeitet durch und die
nächste übung ist wieder im sitzen ihr
kennt es bereits die setups auf der
rechten seite das heißt das knie oder
beide knie bewegen auf die linke seite
genau kennen sie einmal die position
finden langsam arbeiten erzählen sie
konnten auch hier natürlich die
möglichkeit ein zusatzgewicht auch zu
verwenden werden möchte aber glaubt zwar
bei zwei minuten ausfallschritte durch
das ist richtig anstrengend wortwechsel
bauchmuskulatur seitlich hände in
vorhalte vor der brust oder bei der
schläfe auch hier mit der variante er
den oberen bereich anzusprechen in dem
mit den oberkörper nur leicht anhebt
oder den gesamten bereich auch hier
anzusprechen die mit den oberkörper
wirklich ganz hochziehen
ja obwohl sekunden hat es nur sieben
sekunden und atmen und schnaufen und das
seinen oberkörper ganz aufrichten ist
eine möglichkeit 30 sekunden haben wir
durch das heißt man also kannst wieder
aufstehen wir gehen in die
ausfallschritte auf die linke seite
zwischendrin ein stück trinken in der
pause ein schluck wasser ist kein fehler
ja aber du musst die privaten mittel
trinken ja gegen ende der belastungen
der minuten dieser sache die fünf
sekunden nach belastung seitlichen
bauchmuskulatur wechsel ausfallschritt
linke seite
halbzeit geschafft beinachse korrigieren
immer wieder selbst nachschauen ist mein
knie in der richtigen position
oberkörper korrigieren schultern
zurückziehen schulterblätter zusammen
stolze aufrechte position drei sekunden
und 30 sekunden wieder durch ohne
zusatzgewicht die belastung auch
anstrengend für die hertha am minuten
ist der unterschied dann genau 15
sekunden hast noch dann ist die minute
ausfallschritte für dich auch vorbei ok
dann sieht andere seite das heißt knie
auf die linke seite legen und in zwei
sekunden geht es los und arbeiten genau
die ersten zwei drei wiederholungen ist
und zum einrichten der position und dann
wenn man die position gefunden hat kann
man richtig sauber arbeiten kopf bleibt
gerade in verlängerung der wirbelsäule
bauchmuskulatur wird gespannt arbeitet
und wenn's brennt wie feuer glaubt dass
leute dann ist es richtig gut
ja dann passt es gut das kann man hören
das kann man sehen dass kann man spüren
ja da ist bewegung drin 30 sekunden
durch zweite zweite halbzeit quasi für
die du bist fertig manuell genau und die
nächste übung machen wir dann einmal ein
wechsel von bauch auf den rücken
okay auch wenn es anstrengend und zach
wird nicht versuchen unten schwung zu
holen sondern schön langsam mit der
kraft der muskulatur hinauf arbeiten und
seitlich bei den knien vorbeiziehen dass
man wirklich schön in die seitlichen
bauchmuskulatur einkommen drei sekunden
21 und position wechseln rücken
ausrichten ohne schwung zehn am boden
hintern gespannt und die arme regulieren
aber wieder meine intensität weiter nach
vor und die weiter gestreckte arme desto
intensiver wird das ganze
atmen fest schlafen fünf sekunden dann
hat es 30 sekunden später erledigt 21
seiten durch 30 sekunden vorbei wir
wechseln bei in die bauchlage in die
rückenlage für die bauchmuskulatur so
muss richtig heißen
und wir haben wieder die rotation sein
oberkörper
das heißt album linke hand zum rechten
knie und umgekehrt also aus meinen
herbert die letzten zehn sekunden nur
durch arbeiten fünf vier drei zwei eins
und bauch übung mit bewegung der beine
die etwas schwierigere variante und
bauch übung mit beinen am boden ja nur
die rotation aus dem oberkörper ist die
zweite variante thema anbieten und für
die die die minute durch arbeiten ist es
sicherlich die wunsch variante weil das
reich der minuten so zu arbeiten da
braucht man nicht die komplexe
schwierige übung nehmen sondern der
bremer auf der standard variante 3
sekunden durch mit den 30 sekunden zeit
aus und halbzeit beides in einem
drei übungen hammer noch einmal rücken
und zweimal auch dass die letzten kräfte
zusammen sammeln normal richtig
konzentrieren vorbereiten
sehen sie konnten noch stolz die brust
der wert 3 2 1 position wechsele graue
beine kopf ablegen knie strecken und
arbeiten
sie haben ja bislang entspannung für die
bauchmuskulatur zwischen drinnen das
heißt der rücken arbeitet da braucht
kann sie kurz sammeln kurz kräfte
wiederfinden weil zwar übungen für die
bauchmuskulatur amano und die wolle man
ja sensationell perfekt so wie jedes
macht es dann ab handeln
okay die 30 sekunden sind durch knie
strecken herbert nicht die kniebeugen
genau aus der hüfte heraus die bewegung
das wird richtig anstrengen das sieht
man die muskulatur zitat da ist richtig
belastung darauf vor letzte übung
braucht muskulatur
der kranz für die obere bauchmuskulatur
starten in fünf sekunden das heißt es
soweit position wechseln 21 und los
geht's adorf fersen am boden herbert und
für essen in der luft bei manuel und
oberkörper hochziehen schultern weg aber
nicht ganz hoch sowie beim setup sondern
entsprechend nur schultern lösen
hochdrücken und da die hände
sander grad der belastung wenn er sie
nach oben heute wird umso schwieriger
wenn damit die vorhalte geht es dann
wird es etwas einfacher aber 30 sekunden
oder eine minute zu arbeiten ist in
jedem fall für die bauchmuskulatur
anstrengend zwei sekunden eine 30
sekunden durch mangel eine übung für
dich nachher wird du hast nur einer hat
quasi aber das kriegst hindurch beißen
aber er braucht brennt das ist in
ordnung das pferd so daran verändert sie
was muskulär 15 sekunden nach zehn
läufen dabei nicht aufhören zu atmen
abends anstrengend wird net present
sondern weiter atmen weiter atmen beiden
21 und position wechseln fersen berühren
schultern hoch und die gibt jetzt
richtig gas an minuten krank und danach
minuten drehen aus dem oberkörper zur
ferse das ist richtig richtig
anstrengende aber es ist die letzte
übung ersatzteil durch und da braucht
freier ganzer körper freizeit überhaupt
so tolles training dann schon wieder
absolviert in 10 sekunden
nach 521 und aus die letzten 30 jahre
alt kommt zähne zusammen beißen kämpfen
haben die position links berühren rechts
berühren links berühren rechts berühren
noch 18 sekunden ist gleich durch man
als gut intensiv aber okay
maxim sekunden heraus dass ihr habt das
abgeschafft drei sekunden 21 zeit aus
java gut gemacht okay leute das war's
erste einheit dritte woche lockt dann
haben wir erledigt der brauch ist
hoffentlich gut belastet war richtig
unter strom
jetzt hast regenerieren aus lockern und
morgen setzt man dann fort mit einem
training für spezial rückenmuskulatur
uns frites man eben morgen wieder dabei
sein
wir wünschen euch einen schönen tag und
bis morgen